I grew up with
the notion that anything was possible.
My dad was a firm believer
in aspiring to the best of your ability
and even unimaginable realities.
The story of Hello Tomorrow
is so personal in so many ways.
It's an imagined world
that's talking about
the American aspirational dream.
My dad was a salesman.
I grew up in a house where the closet
was filled with products
that were floating through my childhood.
Inflatable ice chests, hat umbrellas.
None of which ever had any success.
But every single one of them
was going to be the key to our future.
One of the things that you try to do
as an actor
is use somebody close to you
as a reference point for a character. To try to get inside
the head of your father
has been fraught in so many ways.
When I think back about my father
now, always like, keep your chin up.
It was because there was repeated
rejection.
It's a desperate position to be in.
We live with miracles at our are fingertips.
We fly with the stars, we split atoms,
we've got robots
taking out the trash. Why
are we all still waiting to live our dreams?
Like all people,
we go through periods of our life
where hope is,
you know, sand in the palm of your hand.
There is a great veneer
over these gadgets.
What they're really doing
is giving somebody an opportunity
to hope for a better future.
And my dad never gave up on that.
There's something so romantic
about that sense
of unbridled, unabashed hopefulness.
I've had some incredibly fortunate
opportunities in my career,
and this certainly is up there with them.
You get to dream on a better tomorrow,
where you can have it all.